you
you
you
you
what's going on everybody
so I'm trying to super low-latency just
to see how well that works can everybody
hear me alright
nothing
I see yes is cool that still seems
pretty delayed it seems like the same
mana delay is regular latency
no delay is fine it's a good at least
for me it seems about eight seconds or
something's almost worse than it was
last week with just normal video widgets
atop I mean like the webcam I could but
why let's test it again
so today I thought we would poke around
on hacker rank I've actually never been
on hacker rank before besides the
homepage so I thought we'd poke around
there and then a teaser for probably
next week we'll start streaming
tensorflow j/s and then after the stream
i'll put out typical videos for
tensorflow dot J's like tutorial videos
mostly since the streams probably take a
whole lot longer to get over the same
amount of content from where is syntax
streaming Mars
puts your face over your webcam I don't
know you're talking about I'm not sure
if that means my webcam is my face or is
it my see me like the subscription or
something is that what's doing yeah I
know you're - I see you're saying yeah
that's silly
put this up here there you go
is that better
so I also just wanted to point out a
crazy person real quick this guy an FTP
SFTP client in Python and tkinter that
looks pretty good I don't know if that's
how he can turn looks on other other
devices or what but on Windows at least
for me it doesn't look like that
yes it's like a bhutesu or something or
Linux
so at least for now I'm just poking
around read it and then hacker ranked
we're just gonna poke around there too
and see see how useful chat can be in
solving problems
ooh public pressure there Google not
reviewing the Maven contract tell me
well after you've been caught I think I
read somewhere they removed that don't
be evil and I forget what the other
thing was they had like another slogan
they removed that too why incognito I
gotta hide from the NSA men they're
tracking everything if you're in
incognito you cannot be tracked in any
way at least that's my understanding how
to get started with deep learning yeah
go to the yeah definitely man if you're
in incognito especially if you're using
a Google product you are covered 100%
I wonder why they got out of the project
if it was just due to social pressures
or what
that's Russia feeling it's good
can i download all the Python libraries
at once you can use something like like
anaconda or some sort of pre boot
pre-compiled distribution basically with
like all the packages in it wouldn't
recommend it but you can
I don't drive in Russia I can't I can't
leave the building so it doesn't really
matter why aren't we able to simulate
the human brain I can simulate the human
brain on
there's really not much difference I
tensorflow in JavaScript and Python the
naming conventions I guess it's like a
90% coverage I want to say for
tensorflow Tijs what is hacker rank it's
like a challenge like a coding challenge
website I guess what do you think
Charles is a lot of linear algebra
what a Python developer should
netiquette employed as a Python
developer I don't know how to learn
stuff that's the same for any developer
though as long as you can learn stuff
you can just get it any job you want in
programming or anything really a
tentative statement yeah Charles has a
lot of statements do though a lot of
rules how do I decide what videos to
make it's just whatever I'm working on
or interested in at the time pretty much
but there's like it's just endless
amount of topics to cover why do people
like Python because it's easy to write
and you can make cool stuff in like no
time what are you doing with a crank
we're just gonna run through it I've
actually never used hacker Inc before so
I'm just curious how that goes I'd like
to eventually be able to do stuff like
that's right Scott if you're a sponsor
you can choose between all of the topics
that I'm interested in possibly doing
which is actually what happened last
time so I did a vote for like the next
topic that we're gonna cover and the
sponsors decided that it was gonna be
tensorflow dot j s no surprise my view
on blockchain it's interesting
technology it's good networking
technology basically it's kind of weird
I think it's weird how like we can have
such hard networking challenges and then
someone comes up with something like
that like the way that it works is not
really all that complex then that we
missed it for that long just is pretty
confusing to me but it's just weird how
hindsight's like so 2020 if you are a
sponsor you could get a role that's
right you get a pretty color on the
discord - and you get a logo next to
your name and you can use all of our
awesome emotes such as oh my gosh
blockchain tutorial dude I just can't
get into blockchain programming man I'm
sorry
I'm not sure what you mean there how can
I store variables in tensor flow for
next time training like you can save
like you can save your models and stuff
like that I'm just not sure what you
mean by variables like you can save your
model and load it back up but it's about
I'm not really sure what else you're
asking there you didn't get a
notification for this if you didn't get
a notification for this video
Howard I don't know how you're here did
you see it like in discord or something
or what I've actually never used yeah I
don't think I've used PI torch so I
can't really answer that I know PI
torches like I'm not really sure it's
gaining too much more steam now but it
was definitely like a huge popular
question that I was getting a lot and
I've just never used PI torch I if I
know how to solve a problem it's gonna
take me a long time to try to solve it
using some other thing unless there's a
really really good reason and I'm not
really sure what that really good reason
would be to use PI torch I hear it's
faster than tensorflow but so part of
the problem is with like just any sort
of even like the higher-level frameworks
too but like with tensor flow what I
really like about it is there's a lot of
research that's done with tensor flow so
when Google does something or whatever
they're always using tensor flow so
there's like already a working example a
lot of times with just brand new
research that's like bleeding edge
research and it's already in tensor flow
for you so I just tend to use tensor
flow pretty much for that reason because
it's already it's already there you
don't have to do any converting or
anything like that
no no never
hopefully no real jobs in my future why
tensor flow j/s I really don't to make
this too much about tensor flow TAS
because that's pretty much what we're
gonna cover next week but basically with
tensor flow edge as the the benefit you
get there is like anybody can run it on
basically any device that has a browser
there's no install required so there's
also like TF light
but you'd still have to install things
and stuff like that where is like
tensorflow @j s is just easy like no
hurdles for people to use it so that's
why the arm project is rip note the arms
actually still going I'm trying to
convince them to send me a second arm
because basically at this point we could
go two ways one is like to have the arms
compete against each other and kind of
be more of like an adversarial type of
system to actually train itself or we
could just detect like the I'm pointing
addicts it is over there I don't think
you can't see it on here but anyways you
can we can also just detect when a goal
is scored and then use that as training
data but yeah in the last stream we were
I mean we were definitely able to get it
hit across the board and it was actually
pretty good at hitting it so know that
that project can still definitely go
quite a bit further it's just I really
want them to send me a second harm we'll
see any videos of coding trains so I
definitely checked out coding train he
didn't get much further than like I
think he just did linear regression I'm
not sure if he's put it looked like that
was like a currently releasing series it
just didn't get as far as I would hope
in the first few were like just talking
about just deep learning in general and
like what his tensorflow so it just
didn't get to the point where I was
hoping for we to get the link for hacker
right just type in a hacker attack
what's your views on Trump I'm surprised
he got to be President I think Trump is
surprised too
I don't think that was this plan
personally to go to college university
yeah I did
yep standing up politic yeah I don't
find that politics to be honest I just
think he was surprised
start coding someone tell me how to
solve this unbelievably challenging
problem I love how the hint is basically
its solution do you think Google
languages go dart will get common in the
next few years I don't know anything
about dart but go is actually pretty
cool the problem is again I it's hard
for me to get excited about go because
all the things that I would do and go I
can already do in Python and it's just
hard to get excited about some project
that's gonna take me like probably ten
times as long attorney let's try this
solution from Andrea's if I can even
type oh my goodness this is taking a
long time to run this code oh we did it
[Laughter]
you don't want to see electronics
tutorials those drums are like super
hacked together can you score a girl by
showing off your Python skills probably
if she is a programmer
no I don't have any other skills so
we're gonna have to continue our
practice chaos or TF learn honestly
nowadays Karis I just haven't done
anything on Keros because it feels kind
of silly to do a Karis tutorial
mostly because so like I just used care
us for example to train the tensorflow
Tijs model that eventually we're going
to use transfer learning for let's see a
guide to the sequential model so I don't
have any Karis tutorials because like
this is it like you just import some
care us
you got your feed for feed-forward
Network here you add some layers choose
your activation blah blah blah blah blah
you do your compilation step give your
optimizer loss and any metrics where is
fit here fit cool you want to save the
model model dot save and honestly the
best thing about Cara's especially over
TF learn with TF learn like if you want
to load a model and I pretty sure it's
the same with raw like tensorflow
before you can load a model and this
might have been totally changed this
because this was the case at least in
tensorflow like 1.0 but if you wanted to
load a tensorflow model you had to
define the model first and if that
defined model didn't fit the model that
you loaded from a file it would break it
so I always thought that was so stupid
like why not just take because the the
saved model is just your weights so when
you load in the weights you can do the
math you could figure out what is this
model like what's the port of this
what's the shape dimensions all this
stuff of the model well I can't do that
so anyways at least what Kerris does the
TF learn again I haven't used TF learn
in a while now but it didn't for a while
do have any way that you could just load
the model why do I got to define it
first and then load the model into it it
should just save that information when
you go to save so anyways caris which is
too easy like I'm not really sure why I
would do a tutorial on Keros
specifically
have you ever done I'd like to think
pretty much everything I do is hacking
but if you mean I don't like malicious
hacking no I tend to just think of
hacking is like my typical way of
solving problems
I pretty much hack my way through
everything but I don't think that's what
you meant do you even know what Kaggle
is I do know what Kaggle is have a
caracal account
I mean I've like tried some stuff
against my own self but yeah I'm not a
I'm not a pen tester by any means it's
Python a good language yeah of course it
is your hacker rank might be different
than my hacker rank
where is oh so I got to solve it down
here this is a lot of text I was hoping
I could get the console to sit over here
this is a long one someone's gonna have
to read that in submit their ideas here
would you have a Python as a pet yeah I
think so
why not
I don't mind the Jupiter notebook
actually most of the tutorials that I
write now I actually write them in a
Jupiter notebook and then convert it to
HTML and sometimes I even keep the
Jupiter notebooks like CSS and all that
I really don't mind the Jupiter notebook
it's just I don't know for some reason I
don't like to do tutorials in a Jupiter
notebook I don't know I don't really
know how to explain it and there's like
certain things that a jupiter notebook
makes a whole lot of sense for there's a
lot of things that it just doesn't if
you're programming I guess like super
linearly it does make sense but if
you're not programming like line by line
or doing like I don't know it makes a
lot of sense for data analysis like if I
was gonna do a pandas series again like
I'd probably use a Jupiter notebook my
Vettius are fine thank you
why the title of the video says hangout
because I spent a lot of time reading
your questions I've got actually a
couple object-oriented programming
tutorials there's like the super simple
one just how to read classes basically
and then there's the slightly more
in-depth one in the intermediate see if
I can find it for you
any tutorial si could learn come on man
yes no I'm just gonna say no and we'll
know who that's to you plan to publish
any no I definitely don't I don't I'm
not a big fan of udemy I think I have a
put if you go to my reddit user account
and then search like comments filter by
votes or something you'll find my
thoughts on udemy a gut of Python
is this your
X in n list is that your solution to
that I'm not really sure where you're
getting RTS unless you mean the result
look tired I always look tired so I got
some coffee I haven't drank enough
coffee books for deep learning know the
problem with books on deep learning is
any technology that they're using and
like by the time a book comes out it's
like two years two years passed whatever
they're teaching you or at least a year
if they really rush it
so that's pretty unfortunate I don't
think you can put like the new lines or
something in there
I think we're gonna have to paste Bennet
thanks Bala we're probably gonna bring
it back we just there was like a huge
overhaul that was needed to be made and
we just slacked how to chat with me on
discord did you just don't you can you
can join the discord and highlight me if
you want I may or may not see it well
it's my take on competitive Pro if you
like doing it go for it we need a good
way for people to submit multiple blocks
here like maybe maybe I could have
people submit it on the discord or maybe
add like a text channel or I'm not sure
if you guys can paste in like a paste
bin or add a gist or something more
Python plays games what would you do
next for a Python plays
best code editor you've ever used Nana
Python played Starcraft isn't it
Starcraft I think I got this confused
last last week I think the issue is it
Starcraft that has like the the deep
learning thing I'm trying to think what
would I call that I want to say it's
Starcraft no sublime is better than none
owl ache and doughnuts fly Python plays
fortnight prom the problem with
first-person shooters is you need to be
able to see somebody at way too far of a
distance the only thing you could do is
uh like some sort of closed quarters
shooting in fortnight and like pub G and
stuff those are to long range you
couldn't do it we were thinking about
maybe doing like csgo so that's a
possibility especially because you can
pro like csgo is like you can use the
command line in there or the console
whoever they're calling it and issue
commands so it's pretty nice pycharm
honestly pycharm probably is like the
best Python IDE is just I don't I like a
simple IDE paper I oh I kind of wanted
to do a Python plays a guard I Oh that'd
be kind of a enjoyable one about
tracking people in a why do that that
sounds like a personal challenge of
you're on like this fraud okay anybody
have a suggestion for how we can submit
the code in hacker rank I think maybe
I'll make a new a new Tex channel or
something and you can put it in there or
we could just pay spin it but I'm not
sure you guys can post pay spin links or
a gist new sponsor
thanks altar rekt MLG Python chess
someone actually use some suggested
Python chests
the problem with chess is knocking
pieces over we could play like a virtual
chess but at least the previous person
wanted to wanted to use like a physical
chess board and that would just be very
challenging
man where did my supply hat sublime text
up yes chest would be amazing
do I like racing games some of them if
they're like a an accurate racing game
am i afraid of the FBI who isn't
if the FBI comes to your door tell me
how you're gonna feel audio recognition
will probably do audio next that was
like the second most voted topic from
the sponsors so that's probably what
we'll do next but tensorflow dodge is is
coming next for sure cybersecurity no
not for me
I feel like doing any sort of like
cybersecurity stuff just begs for people
to show you how bad you are at
cybersecurity and I don't need anything
any of that Thanks
any type of humanoid robot no I'm not
really sure what the fascination is with
like making humanoid robots I was just
watching one I forget where I saw it but
it was like some humanoid robot that
like crawls around and shoots guns and
drives cars and stuff like that I don't
get the idea like why someone thinks
that's an equal zero for AI are these
semicolons what are you thinking
make drone videos the problem with the
drone videos is they take so long to do
to cover something and like I'm not the
best electronics person in the world I
almost always tell people to hook things
up the wrong way how do you manage your
time that's a hard one man I mean just
as long as you're not wasting your time
on stuff that's like not fruitful in any
way I mean that's about it and then if
you like make a list of things that you
want to do that can help too but
otherwise I don't really like I don't
really adhere to any sort of like crazy
schedule or anything like that it's just
mostly don't waste your time what are
you doing in hacker rank I'm hacking my
rank I'm trying to use my chat to boost
my rank so I can get a job
machine learning models working please I
don't think I've ever put out a horrible
a non-working machine learning model you
read my comment whose comment was that I
don't know what that is
we I don't know I think they have jobs
through hacker rank don't they I would
think they would do you think T kenter's
no I don't I don't really think any
desktop UI is really worth learning to
be honest I mean you might you might
have an employer that wants a desktop UI
but I just I haven't had a need for a
desktop interface and ever web apps are
where it's at
even if it's not hosted publicly like
you can host on your intranet or just
locally or whatever yeah I mean if you
have to build a UI like a desktop GUI
then yeah [ __ ] t4 or QT 5 depending on
your licensing needs full-time youtuber
I mean not really I mean I don't I mean
YouTube is probably YouTube accounts
like Python permanent YouTube accounts
for about half of my income though
somewhere around there I don't look like
Edward Snowden Edward Snowden looks like
me what website hosting platform do I
trust I mean I trust a lot of the
website hosting platforms it's the issue
is migrations like I used to I was a
huge fan of digitalocean for a while and
I still am a fan of digitalocean but
they like to migrate like every week I
feel like they're migrating some of my
servers I don't know why they needed to
keep doing that do you think you could
get here without school I didn't study
any math or computer science or anything
related to either of those things in any
school so yeah I think you could
let me try adding enters to this I Thank
You Sergey hi I love your content you're
an inspiration for me to keep learning
coding and improving hope you will
continue to stream regularly I'll do my
best to stream regularly probably mostly
on the weekends that's kind of my goal
and then maybe sometimes during the week
we will see well it's my fault I have no
qualifications man so close the stream
what made you do hacker rank well so
like I'd really like to be able to do
like coding challenges like I'd rather
do Kaggle I think on stream and solve
those although I know like kaggle is
kind of goofy when it comes to as long
as it's publicly accessible I'm pretty
sure I can get away with doing Kegel but
a lot of times Kegel has like these data
sets that can't be shared at all and so
I think if you streamed them you could
get into some trouble arguably I think a
couple of the I can't remember I think
it was the lung or no there was one I
really wanted it was like an NSA
screening or something like that and I
wanted to do that one but I couldn't
because it was like where it was like
where is the it was like the people had
like weapons on them or not and it was
like what quadrant of the body is the
weapon or something like that and like
that one I couldn't do but that one
would have been a really fun one to do
so it was a good like object detection
type task but that happens a lot on
Kaggle where you can't share the data in
any way so it's kind of a bummer but
anyways yeah I'd like to be able to
stream more like Kaggle challenges or
like some sort of some sort of useful
thing like hacker ranks good for like
simple challenges and I haven't really
gone super like this is my first time on
hacker rank but I'm gonna wager that you
don't build like any serious
applications like I think it'd be cool
to build like actual cool projects on
stream but the question is will people
contribute or would it just be me coding
in which case I'd rather just do like
regular tutorial videos what's your most
controversial CS opinion
I don't know I'd have to think on that
controversial probably apply for a while
it was a idle is not a bad editor I
really like using idle I don't have any
problem with that and a lot of people
have a problem with that and it's not
like I think everyone should use idle
it's just I like idle and that just
really rubs people the wrong way for
whatever reason it's just it's good yeah
actually I think javascript is really
cool I don't that's somewhat
controversial but I think idle is worse
DS Code Wars so code Wars is in the list
of things so I checked out code Wars too
I don't personally use any of these like
coding challenge websites I usually can
come up with my own my own sort of
challenge that I'm more interested in
solving usually anyway let's let's run
this one and see queued I love how long
these take oh I think we did it good
work who submitted that one needs some
way of tracking who actually is
submitting these let me see if I can
even find it
I don't think I'm gonna find it
apologize who submitted this looks like
you're a serious hacker don't miss my
text was it was a Mario that submitted
the solution tabs verse space I mean I
want to hit the tab but the tab needs to
obviously be four spaces like needs to
be translated
I just want to pound my space key was it
Mario nobody else is claiming is it
useful to have a game and you mean like
you play a game or you've made a game
honestly I don't know if anyone can be a
programmer I don't know the answer to
that one like when I first started like
when I was like 15 years old I really
wanted to learn how to program and I
tried and I tried and I just couldn't
get it and I thought well I guess I'm
just not cut out and then I don't know
what happened and then I was like 21 I
tried again and like I just understood
honestly think I mean it to Python like
I was trying to learn like C++ or Java
and like I that's why I don't really
think those are really useful to teach
to all newcomers like some people can
pick up C++ or Java or anything out of
the gate and that's fine but I think for
most people starting there's like
starting in the deep end thank for the
sponsor Siri yeah I started programming
when I was 21 a late-bloomer what
resources I used so I was interested in
doing natural language processing so I
used NLT a org slash book and that's how
I learned Python because I just I wanted
to do natural language processing it
just as long as you have something that
you're interested in doing I think
that's probably what's most important
how old am I 62 I knew as soon as I said
I started when I was 21 everyone was
gonna be like how old are you I'm
actually 18
okay so it said we got this right right
okay so we could choose the next
challenge
I'm not 26 you got that one wrong
hey Dad
best books for Python no books
Wow just cuz I said I wasn't I was 26 a
while ago I'm pretty sure I've said that
I was 26 in a video I'm 28
94 yeah no books I I just don't I don't
personally like books so not for
programming anyways I don't mind books
otherwise I should try to get audible to
sponsor me because I mostly listen to
audible nowadays like when I go for a
run or something like that I listen to
audible but I won't read I just don't
like technical books I don't see why I
don't know why anybody likes a technical
book to be honest because you can just
google all your questions and get your
answer immediately but if you use a
technical book I don't know you might
get a more holistic learn like you might
learn the topic a little more
holistically maybe I don't know why
can't I go back in the stream so I can
watch it from the beginning I don't know
man you're not missing much I promise
later on it'll be posted though thoughts
on PI torch never use it can't tell you
I hear it's I hear good things I hate
books
I don't hate books I actually really
like books I tend to read like
nonfiction I like I like the most boring
sounding books ever like philosophy
books or history books that kind of
stuff but programming book no things yes
I'm in incognito so I cannot be tracked
it hides my identity I just answered my
thoughts on PI torch I never did forex
trading I do Bitcoin trading if that's
what you mean and yeah that still runs
what projects can we like anything
whenever someone asks like what I do in
Python I'm like well anything except for
I'm trying to think like like maybe like
robotics or something it's fairly
difficult like if you need a highly
reactive robotics or something it's
pretty hard to do that in Python
it's Bucky for our victim think of
fingers now I'm not sure man yeah the
Bitcoin trading I don't I haven't traded
Bitcoin manually in years but yeah
that's all automated tips on making
money stream to YouTube and ask people
to sponsor you or are you super Chet
well thank coach for robotics for the
most part Python like I would use Python
for robotics it's just there's some
tasks and robotics where you you're not
gonna get away with Python because you
basically are gonna need a wrapper and
so if you don't have the wrapper well
congratulations you're not gonna be able
to use Python how to make money using
Python I just answer that question you
can do like I mean anything man create a
web app that makes some money or work
for somebody do like some freelance work
consistent in trading yeah I trade like
a grid strategy it's just a market
making strategy it just earns pretty
much a fixed amount depending on the
volatility it's like a fixed percentage
of the volatility basically is earned
build the startup yeah like if you know
how to do Python you can just create
endless business ideas right if you're
not paying somebody to do it and hosting
is five dollars a month or less for all
your silly business ideas and then if
one of them is good then congratulations
you're not that rich as a programmer are
you how do you define rich trade no
leverage is a interesting thing like if
you actually model with leverage or
actually use leverage leverage is
applied to the inputs but not your
output so no I would not suggest
applying leverage which your tutorial
should I watch yeah I don't think you're
gonna get business ideas from anybody
else but yourself if you get a business
idea from somebody else you're like
there's probably something wrong with it
and it should be something you were
interested in I mean maybe you could do
rich with knowledge import some money
that works important money from Federal
Reserve
this is some pretty interesting chats do
I ever use freelancer no no people just
find me I think I think most of the time
like so when I do contracting its whole
thing work people generally are
searching for something they're trying
to solve and then they see I'm solving
it on video and then they decide that
they still don't really feel like
learning it and then they contact me and
I have like a you know consulting page
on Python program at net but I don't
think most people are finding that first
they just find and contact me I color
your hair green and stream roblox
possibly doesn't stand him for a lot of
time hurt no as long as you got a little
foot pad you'll be good
this is a very challenging stream of
questions to catch up on
you game sometimes hacker ink problem I
think we need a new problem or is this
the same one let's see here's our
problem I'm not sure how to put this one
on the entire screen you've got the
sample outputs I could scroll it out
this is way too long of a program or
problem I quickly get bored of reading
this problem my commuted now I just
wasn't talking how many GPUs have I
broken - at least it was a it was all it
was tight tight necks and then a tight
necks Pascal you I think you can even
see them in the back let's see I'm using
it as a stand to the to the oculus
whatever they call those things sensors
no I've actually never played for
tonight I played a little bit of pub G
but no fortnight yet for tonight looks
cool I just don't have time to play it
big fan of the standing desk Greg I'd
recommend it to anybody
in fact as long as you're a somewhat
active person
yeah GPUs and stands like I don't even
sit I haven't sat at my desk in months
so you don't even really like this one's
adjustable like I can hit a little
button over here to make go up and down
and I can program specific settings to
it I don't use it it's just I just keep
it standing and as long as you have a
foot pad like I have a wood floor in
here so it'd be very uncomfortable to
stand all day but as long as you have
like a little cushion or something to
stand on it's good and they make like
specific cushions for doing that like
standing at standing desks and then no I
don't have any any problems to be honest
this actually helped I used to get like
a lot of light because I'd go for a run
or something like that and then I come
back and sit at my desk and then you
know I don't know the physics of or not
physics but
I don't know the physical nature of it
all but I think you know going for run
and come back and then you just sit all
that stuff just like pools there and
then I'd start getting spasms at night
and stuff and ever since I started
standing at my desk I don't have any of
those problems like I'd wake up with my
calves like in a full spasm not fun
TV is crap I haven't used keep in a
while but it was very frustrating to use
how long do you stand all day I sit to
eat that's about it
when's Python gonna die no idea what
programs any program like I started with
doing natural language processing to do
sentiment analysis and I think most
people would have said hey don't do that
that's a horrible beginner projects too
big but that's what I was interested in
so you should work on something you're
interested in sponsor for cushions
right like something just for fun
badass Mario that I make in my resume if
you made it I mean and if the resume is
for being a programmer sure like I think
if you can program a good game that's
that's a pretty good thing to put on a
resume if your fits for programming do
you have any Kryptos I have Bitcoin may
be some aetherium I can't remember most
it's just Bitcoin though in before
Bitcoin verse Bitcoin cash debate
here's the question I wonder wonder if
we can skip this question this is this
this hacker ink challenge is just too
long theory in videos no etherium is
like not something I want to cover
offers from big companies at least
interview offers and like Apple Facebook
last week
uber they just there's nothing those
companies can offer me I have complete
freedom they can't offer me any more
than I'm making arguably I don't think
that I can have a better impact I don't
really have any interest in living in
California yeah there's like nothing
those companies have to offer me nothing
against anybody who wants to work for
them but I just there's I don't think
there's ever gonna come a day where
there's just such a difference between
what I think I would be worth to a
company and what a company would be
worth to me especially compared to the
job that I have basically right now
Nexus submit the answer then please
did you have coffee with Bitcoin in
there I don't know what you're asking
try to get a job at dude I definitely
don't want a job at Tesla SpaceX could
be cool
I'm just upfront so every time those
companies reach out I I don't know if I
could pull up the email with uber a lot
of times they're like confidential
emails so I'm not really sure if I can
share them but it's always the same
thing I just tell them like I'm super
happy with my job right now at least
historically anything any company's ever
offered me has never has not been more
than I make the job that I work right
now I feel like I have a huge impact and
I have extreme freedom like I work when
I want I haven't worked for anybody in
like almost a decade it's I don't even I
would be a good employee like I'm just
honest with them when they reach out and
then usually they go away sometimes they
still want to hop on a phone call or
something like that but yeah
I just the interests can't align why not
a job at Tesla any job with Elon Musk
very nice I don't I'm not sure I agree
with that not that working for you no
I'm not on the bandwagon of this whole
recent backlash against Elon Musk
with his like factories and all that but
I'm pretty confident the job I have
right now is better than the job that a
company that Elon Musk runs would be
willing to offer me will you ever stream
on Twitch the hard thing with twitch is
like my audience is here on YouTube so
I'd rather stream to YouTube and keep
everything kind of meshed together on
YouTube everyone's like running to
twitch and I'm in general a contrarian I
don't really like to do what everyone's
doing and I mean YouTube did hit me with
the D monetization and maybe that'll be
a problem
again in the future we'll see and I
might point up having to go to twitch
are you doing that for money only or you
want to be famous only by doing what I
think if I think more people would
respect me if I said I had a job at
Tesla then when I just say that oh I
have a YouTube channel and a programming
website I'm not really sure anybody's
gonna get famous for having a
programming YouTube channel so contract
I'm not sure contracting is better than
jobs I would I'd rather contract for the
same company that wouldn't be bad but
there's like so much time when you're
like deep railing and starting up a new
project for a new client and all that
and getting to know those clients and
getting everything working together I
don't know I'm not sure contracting is
better than a job but it's nice for the
freedom do you have a specific source on
the Internet to learn new stuff
regarding programming yeah it's G oh oh
gee
all I use I just google my questions and
whatever comes up comes up so if if you
really if you're not happy with my
answer of Google and I guess it would
have to be Stack Overflow just the
number of times it's it's come hey is
your ready to ruin your life yeah to fun
decision import all import this yellow
dollar sign
[Music]
so the the GTA self-driving car is not a
recurrent neural network
why don't you deploy your chat bot here
we could I don't I'm not sure if there's
a way to mark so on twitch you can just
mark your stream as for mature audiences
only I don't really see that option on
YouTube and I'm kind of afraid because
the chat bot can get a little a little
interesting
I feel like doing slash studying
everything at once I'm not positive what
you're asking there man like you have
too many interests or what how many
businesses do you have and are they all
web apps well there's the I mean they
depend contracting consulting goes under
like probably like five businesses and
no they're not all web apps so like like
I said I like contracting consulting and
then I also have a few other like in you
know I'm trying to think so at least
with like the Bitcoin stuff that's not
really a web app contracting it's all
things on a web app I'd have to pull out
my tax return but yeah I've got like
pretty sure is like five income streams
Charles here Charles is not
family-friendly that might be one reason
to stream to twitch rather than YouTube
try to get to be press what a
soul-sucking job I don't think I would
want to be President that's what I feel
like I feel like Donald Trump did not
want to be President like why would he
want to be President like too much like
if I was Donald Trump in the way that
Donald Trump thinks I feel like I just
don't think he would actually thought he
would be president I think he probably
was surprised from centex import
knowledge
again I honestly don't think that's
politics to to bring up that I'm not a
I'm not inputting any thoughts on Donald
Trump or anything like that I just as
far as his politics are concerned I just
think as a person the last time he ran
is it seemed like you mostly was doing
it for publicity and then he does it
again and yeah I think I think the I
don't know that it was such a weird
thing and I think he was surprised
himself personally do you like teaching
is that the reason you're creating well
teaching is like a just a good way to to
learn and continue learning and a lot of
times I end up with you actually kid a
lot of times to like if I post something
and it's incorrect someone's going to
point it out and then if people have a
lot of times like suggestions or things
further to look into or whatever yeah I
mean it's just teaching is just one more
part of learning something usually when
people ask me like how this should they
learn I almost always say you also want
to have like a blog or something like
that
currently working on tensorflow Tijs
Oh neural link sign me up I think
technology like that is like almost
impossible for us to really think about
the impacts kind of room honestly like
makes me think about like tensorflow ijs
where there's like the technology to
fully support tensorflow Deus as far as
like hardware that people are carrying
around in their pockets like isn't quite
yet there so it's like pretty hard for
us to really fully fathom like what do
we go what are we gonna do with that
kind of technology and with like a
neural link I don't even think we can
even begin to fathom like what what we
would actually do with that and like the
kinds of innovations people would build
on top of that Josh not a Fannie Demi
there predatory practices against really
both their users and their creators I
would not be sad if you Demi just poof
disappeared yeah since X is sentiment
index started the channel really just to
show like basic programming stuff for
that business that was like the first
business centex comm and then I was just
doing tutorials on like the stuff that I
was learning to program for that
business
and then that's where the channel was
born really didn't set out to be a
tutorial channel at all youtubers who
you liked the most
hmm I don't know man
as far as like programming youtubers
dude I'm blinking on his name now we
talked about him last week someone
someone say the name I know somebody's
gonna know I'm talking about thinking of
Scott if you're here help
I bet I can just
yeah all right yeah it was beauty pie
that's what I was thinking of why nobody
else had the name Derrick Bonnie
actually is not that yeah yeah Shafer
there we go thank you
I'm surprised not more people complain
about shape not Shafer Derek baniyas
he's always using like what what is he
even coating in I'm pretty sure it's
like a WordPad or something but nobody
ever complains about his IDE but when
some taxes using idle it's just too too
too much yeah Corey Schaeffer
otherwise to be honest I just I don't
know I don't think I have like a
favorite youtuber to be honest hmm
percentage of males and females
subscribed I'm not sure I can actually
view that I do know viewers period and
it's nine percent female up from the
original six percent not long ago I'm
not sure if I can I don't think I can do
subscribers but I'm pretty sure it'll
probably translate pretty nicely from
views to subscribers
how to send X make money contracting
consulting Adsense
on both YouTube ads and Python program
Internet ads plus equals one
subscriptions did I mention you could
sponsor the YouTube channel that sort of
thing
Oh in superjet what do you think of the
new boston i i've used some of his
videos before i'm actually on his
channel to be honest the problem i have
with a lot of programming channels like
my issue with the new boston is that you
it's only the basics like obviously you
have to pick up the basics but you've
got to like go a little further than
that if like you're ever gonna actually
learn how to be a programmer you've got
to apply it to like something a little
more complicated than just basics so
that's the that's the only problem I
have with like channels like the new
Boston but if you're taking the basics
and then you're going and doing
something with it that's basically the
same thing like some people can just
learn the basics and move on so I don't
trade derivatives now let me see if I
can pull up subscriber stats I don't
think I can actually tell you guys any
exact figures from my stats yeah I'd
like to do more of this the problem is
like when we have like these huge things
I think somebody whoops somebody
submitted like a few of the things why
isn't my you know the channel
verification makes no sense to me I
actually I got verified like really
early on years ago and then and then it
just went away I don't know why I like
lost that like nothing happened to my
channel I've never had any like
copyright issues no clue no clue why I
went away the whole verification thing
is just weird
it's just all automated are you good at
math no absolutely not
get sent eggs verified how many words
per minute can you write on the keyboard
I don't know I'm not sure man this
Python book come on man
we just answered that you're gonna make
us wind up needing like a gigantic
frequently asked questions are you able
to block udemy ads I think so I think
you can go into like Adsense or
something like that and you can block it
no I'm not in any YouTube network how's
your wife do you have a wife she's good
she is she just graduated she's now a
physician about to start residency
please come up with deep learning next
week we'll be doing tensorflow J s I
feel like the question about the network
just got answered
do you think yes yeah I mean it it
should I mean like in my head yeah or
recurrent neural network should work
better but when we actually went to go
and apply one it didn't work any better
and all I did was suck up more more
memory please don't make a fact
yeah I was saying there way too many
interests and time is less I mean you
just got to pick one and go I have the
same problem I mean it's just really
hard to figure out like what should you
focus on you just got to kind of forget
about the other things and just focus on
one thing if you're just if you're
trying to do way too many things you're
probably not gonna get anything done
what would be the next serious
tensorflow da j is contracting
consulting I mean honestly anything
lately it's been a lot more of like
finance stuff but I also do a lot of web
development contracting insulting I'm
trying to think in the order of clients
so like finance before that was like
deep learning with like it was like a
biotech company and then before that was
like a web development task I don't know
we got to move in there it's been too
long have any pets I got two dogs why
tensorflow J s so people don't have to
install packages they can run it on any
device and you pretty much can use
Python I mean if you can use Python with
Karis save the model and then you open
you can just load up the model and
that's why tensorflow G is like you can
use Python to train the model and then
you just use JavaScript just to do like
transfer learning or you don't even need
to do that you could just sorry I'm
reading this jet and then you could you
could just load the model you don't have
to actually train it any further
nope never played for a night have
streamed in twitch
here's what I want I want I want shorter
questions on a hacker rank that's that's
what we need unless I don't know if
everybody follows like this exact same
structure here and this one we've
already done I think I hit the back
arrow
no tensor flora jeaious doesn't support
Kudo but it can run on the GPU it's it's
WebGL it's a we can we'll talk more
about it next week when I start going
over the Thames flood of Jass but it's
like basically everything's like five
times slower well if I can't yeah it's a
good dune a gank well I didn't mind it
when the questions were shorter but
these are just so cool
this is like way too long of a question
I can't I can't get through that I
already have tensorflow tutorial where
does a beginner start the beginner
tutorials and then whenever you're tired
of beginner tutorials go to something
more interesting I use quite a few GPUs
but mainly a 1080 Ti
so at least with tfj s like there's so
many thing like even though it would be
I feel like I have like a hair on my
nose the the issue or the the reason why
I fjs is so impactful is look you can at
least with like inference so just just
calling something to run like it's it's
a fifth or it takes five times as long
which but it can still be done in
milliseconds so the ability to do that
like on anybody's device is pretty
impressive the fact that you could do
distributed types of training using like
everyone else's devices is pretty
incredible yeah there's just so much
that we can do with tensorflow @j s
because you're not there's no hurdles
for anybody to get over so anybody can
just use your web app they don't need to
install anything like that's just that's
super powerful yeah we fried it
I've definitely at least one GPUs
totally fried another one just crashes
fairly frequently it's probably dungeons
as well open a Iowa tensor flat is
tensorflow without machine learning I
could see tensorflow without deep
learning but we need to learn J s now
you just need to learn how to copy and
paste JavaScript from Stack Overflow
would you consider a series on Finance I
don't know
dude my nose is super freaking itchy is
that just like super delayed I don't see
any super chat did I miss it for some
reason I don't see that super chat in
the chat let's just thought on the
stream is it better to always use care
us on top of tensorflow
oh there it goes wow that was like super
delayed why was that so delayed not
always I mean any sort of word like
always we could say no but it's just
gonna go a lot quicker so as long as
Karis the API has what you're trying to
do in tensorflow it probably is better
so you're not gonna make any mistakes
like it when you're writing like raw
tensorflow
it's super easy to make a stupid mistake
in like it's super hard to debug those
stupid mistakes it's just got a few
flexors but don't forget to sort of
stack overflow
after you make your copy and paste
program absolutely tkinter ver spy game
apples versus oranges how far off do you
think we are from creating general
intelligence I could not answer that any
day now and that could be a hundred
years away
any collab videos with ml experts not
planned I don't think any ml experts
want anything to do with doing a collab
with me
how about a tutorial on ml in unity mmm
probably not but I can't fruit be
compared okay well it can be compared so
like with an apple you can just bite
right into it whereas we're like an
orange you don't want to like you don't
want to bite right into it you kind of
want to peel it first and then like with
an apple there's not like that little
you know the pokey skin stuff there I
try to convert I probably wouldn't
convert the tensorflow to you I mean I
guess you could if it's the raw
tensorflow
so tense flooded jess has like the core
and the layers and so if you just did
the core you could translate just about
everything perfectly
yeah
thoughts on Elon Musk I feel like Elon
Musk could just as he's like like people
study Elon Musk for his like business
expertise but Elon Musk could just as
easily be like studied for his failures
right Elon Musk got super lucky a
handful of times he just he takes on so
much risk that I don't I just I think
he's crazy in that sense but that's
about all I have to say about that I
don't think I would take as much risk as
he does and I don't think I would invest
in his companies because of it what are
your favorite courses to learn deep
learning I don't have any courses that I
would say except for of course my course
no I don't think all like all successful
I think that's like I can't think of the
word but that's not really true that
like everybody that successful takes
like huge huge risks I think musk takes
like way too huge of risks like stupid
risk have I met you don't no I have not
no I have no interest in working for a
company full time I just I can't imagine
what kind of job that would be it's
probably two dislikes because I said not
100% positive things about Elon Musk
good for your back I'm not sure what
that's in response to what happened to
our edit pages man
I have no books to suggest for
tensorflow I would just either find like
a tutorial that your understanding or
you could just go to the tensorflow Docs
or something like that like just use
Google
I just wouldn't suggest getting some
sort of book for any tech but that's
just me I just don't learn from that how
do you choose a new concept to do I just
think of things that are interesting and
then I ask my sponsors did I mention you
could sponsor dude the reddit oh here's
a reddit thanks Scott yeah this crazy
guy with his FTP client what's the other
one we have GUI Lib help
should we go here and tell him to not do
any GUI library how to let a turtle jump
well these are the greatest I have one
week to learn enough Python to be
proficient how do I do it these are my
face is off in a situation where you
have one week to become proficient how
do you do that
can you drop the link to the FTP thing I
think it was this one yeah I think it
only looks that good because it's it's
on Linux I don't think it'll look that
good on Windows Scott but uh yeah here
it is raining computers
how deep are going to go I have no
intention of doing like a full chaos
tutorial I don't really see the point
caris is just super simple i I just I
mean maybe you could get super complex
but even like like yeah you've got the
sequential model and then you've got
like the just the model that you could
actually mess with but I I don't know
I'm just not sure there's any necessity
for I think if I do train another model
like if we come up with another task
I'll end up using chaos for that but I
don't think I'm ever gonna have like a
straight chaos tutorial series it's just
super simple I just don't know what
would make it like once you understand
like how to build a neural network you
should be able to understand care us do
you have like top three or five people
that have made a big difference
know how that I can think of I like
people who are extremely like successful
yet also still pretty humble like like
one person I always think of for that as
like Armin van Buuren like a freaking DJ
but he's like it's just completely
down-to-earth and just a regular dude it
seems like I've never met him in person
I don't know anything when he's like in
reality
but the way he seems I just I respect
that
cuz that that guy could be just like
totally crazy drugged out doing whatever
but he seems like just like a regular
dude like I feel like if you met him and
you didn't know he was a DJ you wouldn't
guess he was a DJ how much do you like
more I have never used pie torch for
anything so I couldn't answer that or it
could and I guess I would have to say
tensorflow
what you guys think of this new reddit
kind of annoys me
yeah he's pretty cool to know the
Bitcoin trading strategy is like super
simple it's just a grid trading market
making liquidity creating strategy
that's about it
how long to become an intermediate I'm
not really sure man a few years it
really just depends especially like if
you're a program are already like no
time at all you read it dislike save
this video yeah the video will be posted
so you can you can go back and listen to
this massive turned into Q&A session get
over there well I mean 100k there's a
like a hard case sample like what is
this yeah goodbye
that's hilarious okay BDD 100k
whoa oh nice so it's like in sequence
120 million well how advanced in Python
do you consider yourself barely
intermediate how much you make a year
six figures new read is terrible I don't
know why they I just don't know why they
changed it I actually kind of liked the
simplicity of the old Reddit favorite TV
shows dude I don't think I have a
favorite I just finished watching
Sopranos super old I'd never seen it
just finished it that was pretty good
I like shows that end that way or a
movie that ends that way nice realistic
ending not you know neatly wrapped up I
like that do you go outside the house
you know like you know once a year
chat hasn't had an in-depth correctly
yeah talk with Daniel honestly I don't
know how you how someone becomes like an
expert Python programmer I'm not really
sure like where do you draw that line
like what would you need to know to be
an expert
everybody wastes time so yeah I waste
time for sure never tried Laura Phil
isn't that's a PHP framework if I'm not
mistaken
not sure why I would try that yeah no-
sports racing
is yeah I think so
Wilfred we were and then hacker rank
decided that they're gonna you know give
us books of challenges and that becomes
somewhat difficult to do writing clean
code
I don't think writing clean code is
expert level clean code using pipe I
just don't know how that makes someone
an expert
like conferences like two three year max
you can you can spend a lot of time at
conferences and like leading up to
conferences and after conferences and
spend a lot of money going to
conferences it can be a kind of a waste
bike racing er like car racing um I used
to I used to track motorcycles I don't
really get into motorcycle watching
motorcycle racing too too much but car
racing is pretty cool sport to me like
f1 that sort of thing
like road courses the combat looks
pretty sweet
what combat could this chat be exported
I'm pretty sure there's like a YouTube
API that you could export it on
so I'm looking at my phone trying to
pull up another website besides hacker
rank
projects well at least to begin just go
we're gonna pry it on the first day I'm
gonna try to at least get through the
basics and get get us to the point of
actually like training model in
tensorflow Jas then the next day get the
web app kind of built around it just
because most people on my channel
probably aren't JavaScript folk and then
after that the goal is here I've been
working on this this one's not done yet
but the bottom paddle is me and the top
paddle is the actual AI and so we're
just trying to get that to the point of
basically learning from playing the
player so I thought that'd be kind of
cool to like have you train the the
actual enemy or the whatever you wanna
call it computer competitor do I came
and keep up with it's actually already
beating me and this is actually a pretty
bad AI at the moment but anyway yeah
this is just like a super simple I think
this is a two-layer 64 node let's see
where are we oh no this one well this
isn't it so this this was like a
different this code has been totally
hacked together but I promise this is
not the that's not the model this is if
there is no model and I want to say the
models just two layers 264 nodes do I
use the drones as fans no you don't want
to turn them on cool projects you want
to do with the res so that probably the
next major project I'd want to do with
the Raspberry Pi is like a growing
project in before jobs like growing
things that I can't grow where I live
some sort of food would be ideal but I
wanted to use that to do you know
because you can use that to monitor like
humidity and then change the humidity
and like pH and temperature all that
stuff you could just automate that
entire process and I think that's kind
of cool
you just did that pics and or video or
it didn't happen projects you've worked
on using Python programming dotnet and
all the projects that are there grow
raspberries you must have heard me
before because I do want to grow
raspberries yeah for some reason I'm
always failed at growing raspberries
that's like my favorite fruit so I
probably try to grow raspberries I don't
know that I've said that I'm not sure if
I've said that I can't remember Wow
let's see
what would you tell an m/l beginner
don't skip over topics I think that's a
probably the easiest thing to do is
you're like learning something complex
like that is to just like if you're not
understanding something just like glaze
over it and skip it I think that's
probably the biggest thing you just
don't want to do that
I'm trying to start up this code Wars
and it's just not gonna happen
yeah I'm pretty sure I can fly the
drones no problem like with video and
stuff like that in my yards actually big
enough to do it
how would you go about making a chess ai
a lot of those things you just start
with like a rule-based and then you use
the rule-based data to train the AI
model and then once you have like a
decent AI model you start taking like
random actions and then successful
random actions
nobody wants code
what's wrong with code Wars
why Phil save the settings I don't know
why I can't I can't do that
how many iterations to train the bait
that's like a totally vague question MIT
food computer I wish I think there's a
forget how that food computer I know
you're talking about I want to say it
was like tooth out of sex so much money
for the food computer though oh maybe
I'm wrong
this one says it's 300
the question though so the issue with
like stuff like this like these little
computers you can easily grow like
greenery stuff like you can grow you
know like mixed greens you can
definitely grow that kind of stuff but
you can't you can't really grow like
something like raspberries has to be
pollinated in there's really no like
look how are you gonna pollinate those
things and so that's why I was thinking
of using the arm to do that that like
robotic arm
code Wars required so you think it's
because of the cookies that I can't use
code Wars is that true I don't believe
in cookies so that's gonna be a problem
even if you're in incognito shouldn't
that should still work don't you guys
strain on your eyes No
have you ever been to Russia
code Wars is pretty fun is it short
challenges
now I'm trying to load code Wars and
it's like going super slow I can't get
it to load why are you using incognito
so the man can't track me obviously
she's cut room what did i do before I
was 21 I paid a developer to like
develop things for me I don't know what
code words is going on unbelievably slow
like I'm trying to load it outside of
incognito but it doesn't seem to happen
Bucky Robertson Richards Bucky Roberts
but no I don't know a Bucky Roberts son
how do you feel about oranges I really
like oranges I now live in Alabama
I just don't like code words meant he
confessed answer is the ugliest
one-liner is that true do they
incentivize like the crazy one liner
stuff well to be honest I cannot sign
into code Wars right now I don't know
what the deal is it's gone it's just
like it's stuck I was at PyCon last year
I didn't go this year cuz I was moving
do you do for living other things not
just I mean what do I do I'm not really
sure what you're asking there
yes I'm married have you visited outside
America that's an interesting way to put
it yeah yeah I'm trying to think of it
only let's see I well I just took a
vacation that grande came in and then
before that the thing if I've been
anywhere else besides Italy I went to
Italy for my honeymoon and then out of
out of the country I think that's it
what were you gonna do toot I don't know
who knows if I hadn't started
programming Python I just always liked
making businesses and it just like I
just was paying people to to do the
development and then I just decided I
needed to do it myself because at least
the developer I had at the time couldn't
couldn't do natural language processing
and just didn't have any interest in
learning it I don't think Alabama is a
fan of of cannabis
how can someone you go Python Prairie
minute knit and then go down to the very
very bottom hire me Python program init
slash consulting do you loose motivation
while working absolutely all the time
and usually that's when you need to stop
working will you ever do paid mentoring
I mean that's basically consulting and I
already do that
a goodnight altar rekt thanks again for
the sponsor how did you meet your wife
so my wife and I actually met in junior
high school and then we well we didn't
it was kind of like one of those things
where a year one of us was always in a
relationship and then basically after
high school we started dating again
so apparently this food computers only
three hundred dollars to make I guess it
looks pretty basic it's like PVC some
insulation stuff some lights a fan to be
honest I'm not sure how that's $300 have
you read the book just for fun no can't
say I have
can't say I have this is kind of
interesting this this video database so
it's got a hundred thousand sequences
and it looks like it's already segmented
for you then you'd have to do the
segmentation I guess that's pretty cool
I actually I'm gonna store that over
here
save that for myself
it's evening this is crazy hold on
wait so it's already got the lane stuff
for you
everything's been segmented for you it's
annotated for you this is pretty crazy
so many open tabs and this is just one
one of the windows
[Music]
best ways to practice Python work on
projects that interest you same thing
with how to become great at machine
learning work on machine learning
projects that interest you so I switch
back to the old reddit I am actually in
my main my usual browser I am on old
reddit oh I think I lost oh here we go
visit old reddit
man I don't like the way that they've
done these promoted that fits to
seamlessly into into reddit now I feel
like it was it like before it was just
like that top post usually and it was a
different color now at legit like looks
like a post and that's really annoying
why aren't you teaching anything today
too many questions
next week we'll do tensorflow TAS and
that'll just be like a live tutorial
basically and I guess I just want one
look at chat or maybe just answered tfj
s questions only
leaked emails
what did y'all think about project maven
I never really read much into what
exactly they were doing I just knew his
stuff with drone AI and stuff why do so
many people ask me where Bucky is he is
a CTO at a venture capital firm now why
did you start with NLP to learn Python
because I wanted to use natural language
processing to calculate sentiment for
companies that were publicly traded
thoughts on JavaScript it's amazing
someone started new on ml if you already
if you're like a JavaScript developer I
guess you could use tensorflow dot J s
but really like tensorflow oj s to me is
just a way to extend my models that I've
built and trained in Python first like I
don't intend to really like TF dot J's
is not going to be quick to train
anything it just gives you options that
you just didn't have before unless you
did like distributed training like I
think TF Jaya says something is
interesting there for doing like
distributed model training and then
somehow you know I'm not sure exactly
how you would do it but there's
definitely a way to do it with TF
jeaious like what would be the most
efficient way of doing that like who
gets the I guess the lowest loss or the
highest accuracy or some combination of
those share it to the rest of the
network continue on that'd be
interesting
javascript versus Python obviously
Python you can just do more with Python
why not use tensorflow Python in the
backend because then you have to you you
would have to do the processing power so
you would have to load you'd have to use
that model run that model the your user
of that model would have to have
internet access
again you tensorflow @j s is definitely
you're gonna probably use Python
tensorflow to train your tfj s model at
least initially and then you're going to
use like transfer learning in the
tensorflow Tijs or you're just gonna
load the model and run it why did you
spend three point eight one two seconds
reading this message
I didn't Python versus PHP I'm not even
sure what PHP is I don't think I've ever
heard of that so it sounds like a set
some sort of like disease or
the same questions repeating over and
over definitely don't read the chat
okay let's see if I can get into code
Wars Python plays rocket League probably
not probably not dude Cold War's is
still going unbelievably slow for me I
don't think I'm gonna be able to do code
worse
trying to sign up for project Euler and
I just kidding 9 I'm trying to sign up
do it deep do I have to actually
register for project Euler I don't to
use it
why don't you earn money from quanto
peon
quanto why do actually earn money from
Kofi your account has been successfully
created that's right yeah I coated my
site by myself when it downloads chat
and training model just to answer all
the questions the comfort oh my gosh it
was definitely correct there we go
top three countries I think it's United
States I don't have to look I think us
is number one and then India's either
two or three
hmm
thank you for the super chat Daniel had
a really upset a uestions housework ask
them if they use Wix Wix reached out
wanted me to do a like a sponsored
series on Wix with incorporating
JavaScript recommend Skillshare I don't
anything about skill sure hey back Umar
I almost did go to visit India actually
there was like a conference there I
can't remember what the name of it was
the problem problem with that is like
the travel time the money just the cost
of just going there is just crazy and
conferences do not want to pay you they
just want you to go for free have been
coding in Python for years but switch to
our what's your opinion on that how do
you ban somebody from the chat let's see
like I'm clicking the butt in it like
the three button kind of you like /ban
we just need to get this guy out of the
chat what phone do you use now my phone
is actually dying it won't hold a charge
I Pro I kind of need a new phone I've
been looking at getting a new phone
thoughts on paid courses I mean some
people feel the need to have to pay for
something so they actually like finished
the course and then also if you if you
buy a paid course I think most people
kind of feel like they'll get they'll
get something quality in return so it
just kind of gives them security I guess
in that so I mean if people wanted to do
paid courses that's fine I've just never
done it I don't actually like I think at
anytime I could do paid courses and like
cash out pretty well at that point but I
think over the long term if you do free
courses the rate at which you're both to
put three or five it does that's the
rate at which you'll grow with free
courses over time I think like if I had
let's say like two years ago I started
doing only paid courses I would I think
I would probably make similar to what I
make right now and what's the point if
you do free courses not only are you
gonna probably make the same amount of
money over a long period of time it's
better for everybody else involved I
want to do
Cagle but many challenges require heavy
and
processing because I have a pretty basic
laptop but when he's cloud what platform
do you recommend thank you for the super
chat Siri a paper space if you search
for paper space on my channel you'll see
them it's like it's just you rent it by
the hour if you turn off the machine
you're not billed but all your data is
still there you're billed like a flat
fee per month for the hard drive storage
space which is it's like super cheap so
it's just but you're billed prorated
hourly for whatever machine you want so
that's what I would recommend and you
have a huge choice like I haven't
actually been I don't know if if AWS has
better GPU service or if they're still
on the stupid K 80s which are really
just K forward he's glued together and
what you're actually buying is a K 40
because I always sell in half K 80s so
like paper space you can actually get
like a current GPU like you can get the
Titan V or you can have you know at
least later technology than the kad GPUs
because it's not actually all about vram
so yeah paper space would get my
recommendation still and the support at
paper space is like super good paper
space is kind of like reminds me of what
digital ocean was for a while where
there just a good service do you spy do
you spy data on quantum I'm probably not
unless you mean thus by the sp500 ETF
what is your rank on hacker rank you saw
it man I think we did like one challenge
wait is project Euler
where are the do we not have is this all
just pure math questions dude I can't
answer these questions I require Python
only do you watch soccer
no no series on AWS iPhone or Android
Android
why you never use pleasure
I don't use patch I just don't like like
sublime text is pretty nice I've gotten
used to just mostly using sublime any
Hadoop know how much math is a must not
much like just general understanding of
linear algebra and multiplying arrays
that's about it like unless you want to
know how to optimize yourself like by
hand but I wouldn't I wouldn't recommend
it why not a serious on AWS dude AWS
just makes me angry like every time I
log into their little platform it's just
frustrating I don't know what my deal is
with AWS it just pisses me off every
time I have to use heat Oh for you guys
it's like so not user friendly I don't
know I just can't get it
how many hours did you spend to me I
don't think I'm an expert in Python so
still going any course on cryptocurrency
just one on that Bitcoin paper that was
it opinion on atom it's okay I don't
I've used it like atom is the default
editor on paper space and so I just keep
using that one I think if you just use a
simple editor you can use any editor but
if you get used to some fancy editor and
then you go to use some other editor
you're gonna have a problem
well you forced your children to learn
Python yeah I won't be mad if they
aren't programmers just disappointed how
did you learn to type so fast I don't
really think I'm that fast of a typer
but just typing or playing video games I
guess like typing on video games
probably where I really learned awkward
workspace wall IDE or text IDE is a text
editor where can we go after the ML
series wherever you want go anywhere the
world is yours spider IDE hmm no I've
used it before but no like I don't
actively use it
I'm too far out of the crypto space I
think most potential is a hard one most
likely to be successful is just sure a
Bitcoin just because its first to market
it has such a huge mode around it but
like that's all I have on my money in is
I think it's just Bitcoin and then I
might have some etherion but not much do
you use paper space or your own laptop
well I would never do ml on a laptop but
I I'll use my main computer if I can but
a lot of times I'm training like
multiple models at the same time so I'll
use paper space to train other models
Diaw knows you mean Thanos are care I've
used Karos and if I do if I do like a
tutorial in the future that a model
needs to be trained it will be using
Kerris you'll probably see me use chaos
actually in when I start covering
tensorflow Tijs
cuz chaos can just easily output the
model that can be boom imported right
away into into times flow edge is
you have any dreams I feel like I've
done that I feel like that's what I've
done already I've sent you a friend what
yeah you in like a lot of other people I
pretty much stopped accepting friend
requests what websites you recommend to
learn Python Python programming net what
is my wife did she's a doctor
thoughts on Jupiter notebooks I've kind
of grown to enjoy the Jupiter notebooks
as long as what you're doing is like in
like an order it's like kind of a data
science type question but like if you're
doing something that's like object
oriented you're like trying to build a
program I don't know why people are like
why you would want to use Jupiter
notebook for it I never had a 40 inch
monitor but I do some of my 4k monitor
that's like I think it's 28 or something
I'm not really sure what its dimensions
are I remember I think it's a 28 yeah I
love it in a monitor
I think 4k like television that's kind
of pointless at the distance that you're
sitting from it but for a monitor it's
super nice to have do you have any plans
to do tutorial on different things I
mean different than ml or what man so
many questions on pi torch guys come on
never used by George dunno
heard good things clearly we're going to
need a PI torch frequently asked
question
wife is the doctor talk about wife goals
tonight at 10:00 would marry again do a
series on blockchain know if you could
would you have a 40 inch monitor no just
multiple monitors like once you hit a
certain resolution like everything's the
same size so you're not actually getting
any more space I'm not really sure why
no I'm just not a big fan of huge
monitors would you force your dog to
learn programming when he grows up not
did somebody asked what my fault yes you
can just google what Edward Snowden's
dad does it's not that hard
did I read your question and I answer it
Wilfred I get sidetracked there's so
many questions in here man dude I'd love
to program in VR problem is I just can't
lay a like I don't even know where to
begin programming for VR the best and
easy way to deploy Django go to
digitalocean I'm pretty sure they've got
like pre-made Django distribution or not
distribution but like a snapshot
basically that you load from I think
that's how I would do it
notice how there's no PHP here but maybe
I sit further away I just I would rather
have two like 26 inch screens than one
40 inch screen which university would
you recommend for a master's in data
science if I couldn't couldn't tell you
oh why does everyone call you Edward
Snowden I don't know man
my name is Jesse Pinkman do you think
earth will be demolished by Python
that's a possibility man that could
definitely be the case thank you for the
99 cents William that's a lot of tabs
open
Docherty talk I just don't use docker no
hacker rank anymore
the problem is they're super long
question and nobody submitted an answer
unless I missed it okay we could hear it
here's what we can do this better work
there we go somebody can help submit an
answer on this one
print the integer sum of the element why
would it say so just anything you pass
in there do you feel the earth is flat I
mean it's flat underneath my feet right
now I'm torn between following data
science or software developing
I'm not sure what you mean by software
development then
currently there's like literally one
computer running in my in my room I have
two more but they're not running that's
a lot of spam ramp
skies that your is that your submission
why did that get no you got that some
map into ray
is it asking it to be printed
at all are you I'm a four foot six
we did it print it no I don't think
print was gonna work made the had to
edit it to be returned so I'm gonna take
credit for that answer because I had to
modify it sorry Scott
what would you recommend to get past the
program I've never heard anybody you
mentioned a programming plateau FYI line
is tech tip says subs don't matter for
views I'm not sure if subs ever really
mattered that much some seem to be
relatively meaningless
this is so confusing it says it was
accepted why is there why is this not
filled in and why are we still on this
page
are you really for six I mean like for
five-and-a-half but can I round up or is
that not allowed we ever reveal your
true height now probably not hit submit
I did hit submit man oh I thought I hit
it
Wow this sounds extremely unenjoyable
hobbit in the case of data science
master's in math other roots which is
best I don't know man
you're asking somebody who like didn't
get a degree in any way related to CS at
all I think there's like a million ways
to get there so
what do you think about I don't know I
don't have any thoughts on competitive
programming talk about ganz please why
do you want why would you want me to
talk about Ganz so bad what internet
speeds do you have it sounds like maybe
you should talk about Ganz dude
Scott you got a channel anymore qunit I
feel like this is one massive Q&A video
favorite game on PC that's a hard one
dude I don't know either there's a
turneth a project cars - I've played a
good amount on and then probably game
call onward but it's like a it's for VR
favorite food I'm pretty sure favorite
food is like a popular password question
so I'm gonna go ahead and skip the
answer or should I lie spaghetti
mom spaghetti actually
now I've never played League of Legends
so I can't really answer that Oregon
Trail oh man yeah that was fun I said
show
I'm definitely wanna let me show that
for some reason I can't accept that
message no matter how hard I try
favorite neural-net architecture
I feel like this isn't a one-liner and
it really should be just a crazy long
one-liner
well now I just have crazy amounts of
spam
your hair needs a haircut does it is it
super long
most powerful PC I've ever assembled
probably the self-driving car PC will
you keep programming in a nursing home
if I could
want to move out of house financially
dependent on parents any suggestions
there's always a way if you really
wanted to move out you can always join
the military that gets you on your own
or just start applying for jobs man
did I miss something in this code
I don't think either of those worked
just in case I'm not sure if I messed
this one of the I could have messed up
your tabbing here possibly
DJI phantom no do you live with your
parents
who doesn't
ah chat uni is slow down trying to copy
and paste this message
nope
all right Scott will try Scott see if
that one's any better
Scot the master are you preparing code
interview I hope not
I'm not getting any of these right I
think I think Scott's ready for a coding
interview
your life hey we got a star
have you seen altered carbon yeah my
wife and I watch that series or actually
I think it's like one season but yeah I
watched it that took a while to get into
it's like super I don't know I can't
quite put my finger on what's weird
about that show but you know it's hard
to hard to get into it but after like I
don't know five episodes was okay
nice guys ready to take on the world
Scott's one of the a is actually that we
wrote that's my star
yeah yeah it's just like a hard to show
to get into why are you so crazy about
Gans man most complex program probably
the self-driving car I don't know or
Python programming that net the most
probably the most caught I guess you
have to define complex but probably that
probably probably would be Python
probably doesn't it desperately needing
a refactor but yeah one of those two
maybe
the kids are berated
so is this our next challenge here I
remember clicking on the next challenge
let me know when a scroll Scot or is
this your solution I don't even know DRD
if this is your solution now or if this
is the previous can you do a back flip
pretty salty over a back flip to be
honest I can never get over the mental
aspect like I can do a back flip if
someone's there spotting me like just
the knowledge that they're there to spot
me but not on my own I just can't do it
I just can't commit do you go to gyms my
wife and I actually just built a gym we
we have like a couple of buildings in
the back so one's like a detached garage
and then the other one I don't know what
was he what was what it was used for if
it was like an old workshop before they
built the detached garage or what and
then we like we just converted that to a
gym for the record I've published a
paper on cans can you do a hand stand
pushup
no no I'm close to doing a one-armed
pull-up that's what I'd like to be able
to do that it's taking a while though
where do you live Alabama
which car actually have three three
vehicles
I don't think you've finished your input
there
did you make those drones sure did
personality type
I think it's on my Twitter you have to
pull it up INTJ I think
I approved your code that you sent but I
don't know why it just doesn't want to
show for me I don't know I can't I can't
do any like I can't click on people's
usernames and stuff in the live chat and
I'm really sure what's what's wrong with
it but I did approve yours but it also
wasn't like the full full code oh yeah
we were gonna look at the user bases by
country I guess I could maybe because
I'm live streaming or something but
stuff is like moving super slow do you
even lift no I mean like I have a gym
and like I like like I go to the gym I
pretty sure that's all you really have
to do I'm not sure why anybody would
lift stuff that's like just hiring that
big tech companies I don't think so no
I'm in Tuscaloosa Alabama now it's like
a good college football town but I don't
know any uh any big tech companies here
DFW is good though there's a lot of tech
companies in the dallas-fort Worth area
we're planning to go back there after
the residency but we'll see
angry people in the chat man
so they've like they've changed all the
analytics in YouTube like you used to be
able to view it by country now it's like
all uh I'll just like bar charts
basically you see if I can go into the
classic studio
I'm 42 years old
it's python venomous I think so Scott
somebody I mean somebody I think it was
uh I'm not gonna be able to pronounce
this right but Nicki tan or however to
say it they were trying to submit
something and well every time I would
hit allow it just like wasn't coming
through that came through but that's
still not complete code you can't quite
end on that no way you're forty to come
on you don't want to have kids I don't
think I answered that question I'll
probably have kids
well I won't that be problem let's see
if I can find our audience demographics
42 years over 46 living in Tuscaloosa
there's only one true statement there I
think you can you do a course on hacking
no no I definitely can't do that I
believe you that I look 24 I I feel like
I probably look more like 21 22 so I'm
trying to find
I feel like demographics should be fine
but maybe plate I feel like playback
location is probably uh like a device or
something
anybody have any idea in this YouTube
analytics how to pull up a country I
would expect it to be in like
demographics age gender here we go
geography
wow that was too difficult
you look like 19 I don't know I feel
like I look 17 yeah number one 22
percent is the United States
number two is India 18 percent and then
after that just a massive drop off to
the UK at four point seven percent and
then it goes from there do you know this
error unable to find yeah I know that
error yeah let's go to unofficial Python
binaries have four point seven represent
actually in Germany is tied at four
point seven so UK then Germany Canada
three one Australia two - yeah India I
don't I wonder I always wonder if other
tech channels are also like India number
two or number one and I know like where
you post from has a huge impact
so like since I'm in the United States a
lot of like what I get suggested to is
people in the United States any videos
in YouTube demonetized yeah there was at
least a period where like everything I
submitted was getting D monetized now I
just upload to unlisted and then if it
gets to monetize I just dispute it and
then I post it once that dispute is over
but yeah they were like they were to
monetizing just anything and it was
really weird I don't really know why
they were why that was happening but you
know just bad algorithm
happy to share the Python tutorials
Scott where's the answer here
how much of your time do you spend
coding in which language lately I've
been like just copying and pasting
random stuff from Stack Overflow with
JavaScript just to make stuff with tfj s
have you ever tried stand-up comedy no I
don't think I'm that funny I laugh at
myself
let's see plus/minus array
actually I haven't even read show us I
don't have a girlfriend so that would be
a problem if I did though I am Edward
Snowden look at the I'm incognito that's
how it's done it leaves with JavaScript
definitely got to do a lot of copying
and pasting yeah that's right Scott is
YouTube know like the whole like
tutorials and stuff accounts for about
half of my income but a lot of that
still comes from like Python programming
dotnet either ads on there plus equals
one
do you feel question offensive no I
haven't seen any offensive questions yet
I've seen some like trolling questions
JavaScript furs Jango you what's with
these apples and oranges again yes
yeah JavaScript and Giants no Dex
so snow is actually my middle name
so snow Dex is still me when do ya when
did that when do you or when did I I'm
gonna assume you mean like when did I so
I was working as a waiter in college
like part-time I worked like three to
six hours a week or something and then
that place went out of business and then
from that point forward I just stopped
applying for any jobs and just kept
working for myself I answered your
question if you're not gonna stop we can
help stop you I told you what to do just
go to the unofficial windows binaries
and install that way if you don't know
what I'm talking about go to the PIP
tutorial 36 out yeah also I was working
already at that point though like I was
already working for myself running my
own business like I just kind of I just
kept the part-time job for secure
insurance purposes basically just for
security and then when they went out of
business I was like well what's you know
I'm not gonna go apply again so that's
why why do businesses because of bad
service yeah yeah what did you working
for Google no no Ganz
Scot when are you gonna submit the
answer I'm just kidding don't get angry
I've been meaning to read this one I
don't need I didn't even read the
question let's let's see if this
actually works and then oh no okay so I
have to waste my time reading the
question Scott you gotta fix the code
now you know exactly what it's like when
Daniel works with me Scott
have you watched I've seen like a few
things from Silicon Valley but I have
not watched that show like I don't know
I've never watched like a fully even
episode of that show who's your favorite
youtuber Centex
did you start smoothly or business or
was it a pain in the neck I don't think
anybody starts a business smoothly it's
always a pain and there are definitely
times where I had like maybe two weeks
of money left and then I was gonna
definitely be broke but even then I
always knew like well if you you could
always just go get a part-time job again
so even if you went broke running your
own business okay like go work for
Walmart or something while you stack up
some more cash and try again will you
ever do pair programming
maybe maybe with Daniel or Scott I'm
basically doing pair programming with
Scott that's what's happening why are
you in incognito
it's hide from the men as I've said
which person do you ever get admired I'm
not sure what you're asking me we're
waiting tail wagging tables the guys are
pretty good money I mean if you're a
decent waiter at a decent restaurant you
can make good money like it's probably
one of the best no skill types of jobs
you can you can get so like when you're
in college or in high school or
something waiting tables is that's good
plus the whole all the benefits of cash
business do you watch PewDiePie
I'm afraid to answer that question have
you ever been told that you look like
Jesse Pinkman once maybe twice just got
here what do you up to with hacker rank
I'm using Scott to get up my rank but I
don't see any any latest solution from
Scott
I'm gonna be honest I don't think I'll
do hacker rank again I don't like these
kinds of like challenges it makes me
like want to make my own little
challenge site have a little patience is
I don't have any patience again just ask
Daniel how what it's like were you
successful as a youtuber from the
beginning
no YouTube's just like one of those
things you just slowly start building as
long as you keep working at it you'll be
fine I really wanted to shout your name
but I'm not alone in the house right now
so I'm not gonna do that again I don't
think I can actually show you guys my
analytics but YouTube's just like steady
growth you could probably go to what's
that social blade and you can see
although social blade doesn't go back
very far I don't think I don't know if I
can easily take a screenshot of that one
what's your life goal develop ai it
takes over can't refuse then Oracle oh
man I just made a mistake let's see here
let's do rolling
this ligand love man I just cannot
believe how obsessive so I tried to use
code Wars could not log into code Wars
for some reason I can try again it was
it was just lagging Lego just load and
then fail eventually I don't know if
it's because I'm streaming or what I
just don't know what's doing will you
close the channel for a jot no Google
actually hasn't approached me for a job
I did get the little Google thing I
figured what that challenge is called
but it's like an imp browser and I
couldn't even do it man I think I got
through like level seven or something
like that and then it like I started
spending like six hours on one of their
little challenges and I was like a chem
done I couldn't do it trying to find
there we go
I just can't imagine a job that I would
work at Google you know like something
that would be just as rewarding still
give me freedom or pay better like none
of those jobs that I've been offered yet
you even beat one of those things let's
see if I can get code Wars working now
maybe maybe it'll work maybe not I don't
know
girls of tanks
I'm like unbelievably lost already
that's PHP
this looks even more complex than hacker
rink
it's got where's the solution did I miss
it
I don't think so
I think we'll have to I think in the
future we're gonna have to try maybe
kaggle maybe try to solve some keggle
stuff but still next week it's gonna be
tensorflow Tijs
in less questions hopefully why not as
you toriel if no and that mm maybe
sometime in the future C++ but probably
not probably not I don't even know it's
running right now on Kegel
yes Scott where is the solution oh my
god Oh another YouTube video challenge
25 thought I cannot this always bothers
me it's people solving these problems
for twenty five thousand looks like a
million dollar problem for Google or
more like multi-million dollar problem
and you'll get twenty five thousand
dollars for it and you won't even I bet
that's not that's probably not first
prize it's probably ten or fifteen five
and something or something like that
let's see oh it's just five thousand per
team who has a travel award
oh but you got to attend the conference
you also get an interview yeah but and
what a good gig if they could get a
solution to the that kind of a problem
for I remember I saw one for it was like
for detecting malware and I think it was
for Microsoft and I was like twenty
thousand or twenty five if you can do
that start your own business don't share
it with them and then sell your business
for millions to them there's just a
better way there's just a better and you
can get aqua hired and you'll still work
for Google at the end have you ever
thought about experts so after tensor
float so next week we're gonna do tensor
flow at J s and then probably like so
like next Saturday Sunday will be tensor
flow Tijs live streams and then that
week I'll probably release that tfj s
like video tutorials and then after that
we'll probably be getting into sound and
speech generating ai so a couple weeks
you know I'm not sure it's worth
billions but it's well the map okay the
malware detection depending on how good
you can do it might be a billion-dollar
business the video understand or I'm not
sure I'd say that was it's a
billion-dollar business but it's a more
than $25,000 and a job at Google
they actually don't have too many up
right now my goodness
the best ones 70,000 needs a million
dollar ones Cancer Research
is there a cancer did I miss it you got
particle tracking I don't think there is
a cancer research one up here right now
yeah maybe in the future we'll do a
kegel live prom with hacker rank is like
there's just sky for hacker ain't frost
look in the discussion I'm sure you
could just Google and that's probably
what's been doing this whole time is
just googling the answers
kaggle live maybe in a few weeks we'll
do we'll do some Kaggle I've gotta find
a good a good competition some of these
are just there'd be too much sitting
involved like I could do we could do
easily like digit recognizer or the
Titanic one that would be easy to do
live but some of these don't have an
actual solution to them like so you'd
spend a lot of time just kind of sitting
there thinking and that's a pretty
boring thing to stream Scott did send an
answer I don't even sure if I'm on that
tab anymore is it this one is it this
one yeah you got a wrong answer
nope it's God did you even check check
gotta check your check your code shreem
eating food I am getting pretty hungry
but I don't think I'm gonna stream that
my apologies
if you have a pastebin link just send
the end of the link if you get I'll just
copy and paste that for anybody who
can't post the pastebin print instead of
return no I don't think you want to do
print uh-huh I mean maybe it does cuz
it's not actually the other ones
actually did output it but surely that's
not it
why guys are behaving very stupid maybe
cuz we're stupid no JavaScript tutorial
but when we go over tensorflow Tijs I'll
at least explain the simple JavaScript
that we're gonna be using killing me
with the Gans man try printing
everyone's it's not gonna be the
solution if it's the solution it's just
not that's that's not it okay good
didn't work see not the solution
I've done both C++ and and Java I just
don't see the points I'd really like to
learn C++ for like robotics reasons but
other than that definite and hard no to
the to Java
the sky
Scott you're not even on discord man
let's try it
still wrong the man
no never done Lisp
how do you keep I definitely don't
I'm waiting for the the paceman to load
Jason
you need to print all three lines
dang Scott has been bested that's
embarrassing
dang r.i.p to sky
all right it's not really time for me to
to eat so I'm gonna get off now so next
week we'll do tents float J s and then
probably after that audio and audio with
deep learning that's probably where
we're going
nice work to Scott and finally Jason at
the end there I think Scott just
couldn't handle the complexity
it Scott says this is a bad idea for me
to say don't say it's time for me to get
off now
alright and with that I'm out of here